[Music]
all right let's go to christina in omaha
nebraska what's up christina
hi how's it going i'm good how are you
i'm doing great fantastic what's up
all right i have a question i'd like to
get your perspective on
um i have a wonderful all right
i have a wonderful sister who has down
syndrome and she is not getting the care
that she needs
and my question is
how do i confront my mother about these
issues when she believes she isn't doing
the best for her daughter
she believes she is doing the best or
does not believe she's doing the best
she does believe she's doing the best
okay
um walk me through what care is missing
what's going on
the biggest
thing is that
she is having trouble with
um mental health she's
i've heard her describe
that she has hallucinations that
um
that trouble her on like a daily basis
as well as
um
pretty vivid nightmares
okay she also has she's been going into
extreme isolation
um where she won't
um
try and make friends
she also doesn't get very many
opportunities to make friends
um is she in school
she is not she has not had formal
education since she was in kindergarten
my mother um
is a homeschooler but she
doesn't
um
give like
structure to homeschool it's more like
uh free-form education
not yeah okay you're you're and you know
this i'm just saying it's out loud your
sister has some
very
serious needs
that can be met
have to be met legally right um but can
be met with great care and love and
professionalism in a local school
yeah and she needs those desperately
um
the things you just told me
hallucinations nightmare isolation no
formal connection with other kids is a
dangerous spiral for a young child how
old is this is your your sister
she's 17 she's 17 how old are you
i'm 28 28 okay
um
yeah yikes uh
have you had this conversation with your
mom before
no okay i've i've recently been on my
own healing journey from my childhood i
can imagine okay
um
so
you have to you have to you have to call
the child protective services
okay
this is what i was afraid of
you need to do it today
you do it today yeah yeah today or let
me tell you this i'm going to do it it's
hard because i know i'm going to do it
burn bridges i know
listen the bridge has been burned
yeah and your sister's on that bridge
and it's on fire
okay
you didn't light it
it's not by your hand but this fell into
your lap so now you got to deal with it
and this shouldn't be your job because
you're the child and it is
but someone's gotta look after that
little girl
okay
okay um i'll give you uh before i call
because now now what i have is a report
of a minor
who is struggling so before i
send in a uh report i'll give you 24
hours okay
okay here's what the follow-up looks
like okay
the follow-up it looks like this
you sit down and tell your mom
um well let me back out it sounds like
you're this your mom won't hear this
conversation it's not even a safe
conversation to have is that is that
true
yeah it's it's like
yes that is true it's like i want her to
listen to this i i desperately want her
to but in the back of my mind i know
that she won't okay all right you're
right so
my approach all the time is to sit down
with somebody and have a hard
conversation with them
about what i'm going to do
if they don't change fill in the blank
okay
but i also one of my core tenants is
only speak if you can be heard
and this conversation i trust you would
be a waste of your time
and might even endanger your sister
further
oh okay okay
um what i don't want is an adult in your
sister's life to come and say hey if
anybody asks you you better say this or
you're going to be in big trouble you're
going to get hurt again or whatever
hallucinations nightmares increasing
isolation this spinning out
my first thought
the question to ask you is is there a
chance she's being abused
um there's 100 percent chance she's
being uh mentally and emotionally abused
yeah
is there a chance she's being sexually
abused
not to my knowledge okay
um
okay
you need to make that call today
okay
and
yes it may blow things up yes it may
whatever it's the right thing to do
because your sister needs some some
significant um
interventions asap
okay
my hope is that the local school can
take care of that there might be a
chance that you end up having to take
her for a season
or an aunt that lives in that area takes
her first season and you get enrolled in
a public school
and they'll work with her um but that
isolation for what three four years you
said
um
yeah yeah probably
at least
when you say she's 100 being
psychologically and emotionally abused
what do you mean
i mean that it's coming from my mother i
have witnessed her
ex gaslight her and um completely
ignore her
um request for help
like she's told her that she's in pain
or is she struggling with something and
my mom has told her
no you're not
you're making that up or you're
doing that to get attention or something
like that
yeah you got to step in right now okay
okay okay
are you gonna make that call
um
gotta have gotta have to huh
yeah i would tell you besides the
ethical moral obligation and besides the
fact this is your little sister you have
a legal obligation you know of a child
that's in distress it's being neglected
and or abused then you gotta make that
phone call
okay okay how do i
how do i
i don't know how do i tell my mom that
i'm doing this
i don't know that you need to
oh okay um
if if it was my
my parents wouldn't be in this situation
if it was an adult that could hear you
then you would sit down you'd either
have a phone call or you would go sit
down in person and say hey um
i can no longer sit by while my sister
is struggling with these extreme
nightmares with the extreme isolation
with the
the
emotional and psychological abuse that's
going on in this home with a mom and dad
that completely ignore her needs she's
not doing well and i'm scared about the
outcome here and so
um either she goes into public school
effective tomorrow
we go enroll her tomorrow
so she can get the needs and services
that um
she is in desperate need of or i'm
calling cps
okay okay and when you call cps you tell
them i'm 28 years old my younger sister
has down syndrome she's 17.
and
she's being psychologically and
emotionally abused she's having some
mental health breakdown issues and
they're being completely ignored
and so i'm calling to make a report of
child abuse
and i'm willing to take her into my home
while you'll investigate this
right okay
lay it out that cleanly facts are your
friends not does it need a long dark and
stormy night it just needs here's the
situation i'm reporting this call and
i'm willing to step up but i need you
all to go in and do your job
right okay
now if you think there's a chance you
call cps and they say great we're gonna
go look into it but it's gonna be about
three weeks or four weeks or she an
immediate danger do you know of any
physical abuse going on or whatever
um our backlog is x and y that may
happen
um
it may be that you go sit with your mom
and say i would like sister to come live
with me for a while
right and just get her out of your home
would sister come live with you
oh yeah i would
it would be i would welcome her to come
live with me okay
that may be that may be your next step
um
i can feel my blood boiling here like it
oh man uh man i don't talk about a lot
on this show but i spent the
bulk of my career working with kids with
young people and young adults and adults
with special needs
and
oh man
i i have a
rage inside of me
uh people don't honor and love and take
care of kids special needs
also by the way parents listening
homeschooling is great
i'm a huge fan of it i love it
especially homeschooling done in a co-op
where you've got other people y'all are
connecting and they're learning from
different people i love it
but homeschooling just because you watch
a lot of internet stuff and you're like
these schools are teaching them this
stuff
and you do nothing
golly you're hurting your kids when you
do that
kids have to have structure they have to
have boundaries they've got to have
intentional lessons intentional
um
pedagogy
and
golly dude love your kids enough
to turn the internet off and at least
send them to a public school at least
send them to a school that you can
afford at least send them to a
homeschool co-op where they can actually
get the education that they need if
you're not going to provide it for them